beans are so undervalued and
underappreciated so thinking about all
the things that we talk about and eating
better one of the things that often gets
left out is people with food insecurity
or nutrition insecurity like who has the
resources for this food how can it be
culturally appropriate there are so many
kinds of beans we got lentils we got
dolls pulses uh chickpeas hummus think
of how many amazing bean-based dishes
there are and how inexpensive dried
beans are super nutritious high fiber
the highest of any kind of plant food of
protein so if you are trying to displace
some of those animal-based Foods
beans are the obvious answer and it is
embarrassing how few beans Americans eat
compared to the rest of the world and
the other food groups so if I were to do
anything
I do want to focus on what we said in
the beginning more vegetables more Whole
Foods less added sugar lesser fine
grains
but almost separate than that
beans